President Trump
ran in 2016 as a populist not a
conservative and that's why he won
populism is popular at its best it's
also positive and that's what we argue
for on this show positive populism
pro-worker
pro-family pro camera themes of my book
positive populism but President Trump
needs to be careful some leading
Democrats are trying to steal his
winning populist message look at
Elizabeth Warren yes it's easy to knock
her on her dubious claim of Native
American ancestry and by the way
President Trump literally just did that
minutes ago on Twitter if you're
interested but if you listen closely
she's basically running on the Trump
message 2016 the populist bedrock of
that platform was to make government
deliver for working Americans not the
big donors and the big corporations the
focus was the middle class and working
families and now that's Elizabeth
Warren's focus to the middle class in
this country has been treated so
unfairly we will cut taxes for all
working in middle-class households in
America America's middle class is
getting hollowed out what's happening to
working families in this country why is
the path getting rockier but the echoes
go beyond the big picture look what
Warren said about Washington's
corruption when she spoke in Iowa last
week we need to change the rules in
Washington yes and it's about money in
politics it's about the influence of
money I have the biggest anti-corruption
proposals since Watergate yes
[Applause]
how about we blocked the revolving door
between Wall Street and Washington you
think I think she needs the biggest
throat lozenge to be honest anyway great
idea about the revolving door but where
have you heard that before oh right in
2016 wasn't there something about
draining the swamp fighting big money
and yes blocking the revolving door all
of that money that's going to Hillary
and Jeb and Scott and Marco and all of
them the people that are putting up that
money or it's like puppets a five-year
ban on lobbying by executive branch and
congressional officials they're not
going to be too happy a lifetime ban on
government officials lobbying for a
foreign government now it was unusual
for a Republican candidate and so was
what Donald Trump said about student
loan debt and health care we will lower
the cost of college and solve the
student loan crisis universal health
care I am going to take care of
everybody I don't care if it costs me
votes or not everybody's gonna be taking
care of much better than they're taking
care of now Wow cutting student debt
health care that takes care of everybody
that 2016 candidate sounds uncannily
similar to this 2020 candidate we pretty
much believe two-thirds three-quarters
of us want to see kids get some relief
from student loan debt want to see
affordable health care and health care
where you can't cut people out with
pre-existing conditions now I suppose
imitation is the highest form of
flattery and Warren agrees with Trump on
the need for infrastructure spending to
our roads are bad our schools are bad
our highways our tunnels our bridges our
bridges are falling down you see those
reports they're dangerous many of them
so we're going to get our infrastructure
taken care of it's going to be in jobs
but we have to do it for our country
what's happened to federal help for
infrastructure where's all that new
money that was promised for
infrastructure that would help us in
building more
that would help us in building more mass
transit that would help us in dealing
with our traffic congestion good
question what did happen to the
infrastructure plan but this political
Odd Couple even seem to agree on trade
and China I'm going to instruct my
Treasury secretary to label China a
currency manipulator the greatest in the
world any country that devalues their
currency in order to take unfair
advantage of the United States and all
of its companies who can't compete will
face tariffs and taxes to stop the
cheating they look the other way as
China manipulated its currency to
advance its own interests and undercut
work done right here in America China
has weaponized its economy without
loosening its domestic political
constraints sounds like somebody went to
Trump University look we could go on all
night but I suspect that it's quite
enough Elizabeth Warren for all of you
and we're certainly not endorsing her in
fact many of her actual policies would
be disastrous for working Americans it's
also true that many of Donald Trump's
populist promises have been delivered
top of the list of courses jobs and the
economy the poverty rate is at its
lowest point in a decade not by accident
but because of actual policy like
deregulation and tax cuts over four
million jobs have been created since
Donald Trump took office with the lowest
unemployment in half a century
and earnings rising at the fastest rate
in a decade not by chance but by
policies that boosted business
confidence and encouraged the hiring of
American workers and the clearest way of
all in which President Trump has
delivered his populist promise for
exactly the people he prioritized
manufacturing industry has boomed after
suffering for years over 400,000
manufacturing jobs have been added under
President Trump compared to a net loss
of over 200,000 under the eight years of
President Obama last year was America's
best manufacturing performance since
1997 since before China
in the World Trade Organization and
sucked all those jobs away and beyond
the economy and despite the endless
claims of the elitist establishment that
the swamp is not being trained
the President did follow through there
as well he signed an executive order
banning administration officials from
lobbying on behalf of a foreign
government and put a five-year ban on
executive branch officials lobbying the
government after they leave office but
to stop the Democrats turning populism
into their winning message in 2020
President Trump needs to reclaim the
mantle and he's got a perfect
opportunity in just a couple of weeks
time mr. president here's how you can
renew your populist revolution in your
State of the Union address with five
positive promises that will help working
Americans one on jobs fight the threat
of automation by guaranteeing retraining
for every worker who needs it that means
boosting your national council for the
American worker which helps prepare
Americans for the needs of the future
workforce under this effort led by
Ivanka Trump over a hundred companies
have promised a Reese kill a total of
over 4.3 million workers that is a great
start but you can make much more of it
to give us that massive infrastructure
program you promised make a pledge that
by 2030 America not China will have the
world's most modern systems for
transportation communication and energy
three rebuild America's struggling
neighborhoods to where the urban
suburban or rural you've already
established a White House opportunity in
revitalization Council you've got a plan
for Opportunity Zones these can be the
vehicles for a real transformation that
helps exactly the people who backed you
in 2016 for on health care you promised
to take care of everyone and then the
ideological nitwits in Congress took you
off course trust your instincts work
with Congress to deliver guaranteed
health care for every American and fifth
keep draining that swamp with a move
that every American will cheer ban
foreign government lobbying
foreign governments have embassies they
have ambassadors
why the hell should they be allowed to
use swampy lobbyists - and why the hell
should members of Congress and their
staffs be allowed to deal with them five
populous promises that will show you're
putting working Americans first
don't let elizabeth warren and the
democrats steal your winning message we
know that their brand of populism will
set the country back but mr. president
you've got to show how your version can
move America forward tell me what you
think of all that at Steve Hilton X and
that next breath
FNC